all right a new cbs n originals episode
explores the hot button topic of what's
been called
cancel culture it's defined as
withdrawing support for public figures
and companies
after they've done or said something
considered objectionable or offensive
a recent poll from morning consult and
politico
found americans are split on the issue
with 46 percent saying
cancel culture has gone too far the
newest episode of cbsn's speaking
frankly series
dives into the debate take a look we see
a number of people
who have been publicly shamed who have
gone viral because
they were harassing black people
harassing people of color
and when the public galvanizes around
one of these clips what folks are doing
is saying that collectively this is not
acceptable
for our society there's a benefit to
calling attention to
a behavior that is genuinely causing
harm to other people but
it's one thing to go after a celebrity
who has said a terrible thing
and it's another thing to go after a
private citizen who happened to get
caught on film
in a really bad moment those are not
equivalent
cbsn originals executive producer adam
yamaguchi joins us now adam good morning
why are people so divided on this issue
you know this really comes down to
values those who have been driving
cancel culture
want to create a society that is
equitable that is tolerant
that is inclusive and that cancel
culture really is a mechanism to
to to push us in that direction by
calling out people
and organizations who are on the wrong
side of progress
will actually help society make real
progress
now on the other side are those who say
that
people are offended by anything and
everything
we as a society have become far too
sensitive about the words that we use
and that it's also it's almost criminal
uh to say something that offends and so
there's been a real backlash against
cancel culture
um in in the face in the name of
political correctness
uh people are being punished for words
and actions that were said
far far long ago at a time when those
words or ideas were deemed acceptable
uh people are being called out on video
for experiencing a particularly bad
moment where when they may have said
something
uh that uh you know perhaps was was was
off color and so
people are being punished uh people are
losing their careers and their
livelihoods
um through this cancer culture adam
people have been
effectively banished in the past if you
will but
social media has really accelerated the
process
hasn't it absolutely
um people have people who previously
didn't have a platform or a voice to
call out
others particularly those in power who
have
you know perhaps acted uh
inappropriately but have been able to
act with impunity
have been called out we saw that a few
years ago with the metoo movement
and we are experiencing in this moment
as the nation reckons over its racial
and
and cultural injustices yet another wave
of companies
organizations and people who are being
called out for being on the wrong side
of that as well well it's important to
underline bad behavior
what's sort of scary in the social media
aspect of this is it can happen
so swiftly and you can develop almost
kind of a mob mentality
and end up discouraging sort of a deep
debate on certain issues
absolutely and that's that's the big
conundrum i don't think anyone really
has an answer as to how do we fix this
how do we go back to having reasoned
rational nuanced discussions social
media has been the catalyst for this
latest wave of cancellation and
as you pointed out social media viral
viral videos
don't encourage nuanced discussion they
encourage
quick instant action cbsn originals
you're focusing on on culture wars this
season adam tell us about that
sure you know in the run-up to the 2020
election
we find ourselves at odds with each
other in a way that i don't think we've
seen
in an entire generation we are so
polarized
and i think it's important to dissect
when and where those social figures are
are occurring so we're asking the
question
do clashes over language and ideas
actually foster real meaningful change
or are they simply bandaging
bandaging real issues and problems with
words that coddle us and make us
feel good um and and dividing us in
in the process and so some of the
episodes that we have upcoming we're
going to be looking at
fat shaming whether the celebration of
all body types
is a positive development for people or
whether it's actually leading to
more problems or health issues for for
for those who are
uh considered obese we're also looking
at
online censorship who gets censored
online
for saying what all right looking
forward to all of those adam yamaguchi
thanks adam
cbsn original's latest speaking frankly
episode called cancel culture
is streaming right now at cbsnews.com
cancel